now i want to turn um to my dear friend
dr elisa pressman um i just sat down
with her
um and i did her very first podcast when
it launched it's called raising good
humans it has since become a juggernaut
it's a total hit a top-rated podcast i'm
so happy for her we just did our second
one about two years later
um and um
this episode that we have done is very
personal to me so i want to bring her in
so we can talk about it because it's
going to launch this friday so please
welcome dr elisa pressman
hi
so elisa i ask you
why did you call this raising good
humans because i think it's the greatest
title because your podcast is not
necessarily just about kids it's about
the adults that we are trying to
not only raise those kids but raise
ourselves that's exactly what it is i
want to have a platform to share
the research and the reality and the
vulnerability and
the wonders of raising human beings and
not just children because you cannot
raise good humans without looking inward
and coming to terms with the human that
you are and i loved our conversation
it was so personal and you were so
vulnerable
and
in the
in this time of year people are feeling
really reflective and overwhelmed and
they're not alone i think that's
basically what
we shared okay so we have our second
episode um that comes out tomorrow and
i just am very excited about this
podcast because i was able to
discuss further a lot of things that i
have
kept inside for a lot of years
and
i
have kept so much of my parenting
journey private because i'm so
protective of my children
what i've realized is that
in protecting them and not necessarily
sharing my children i can share
what it has been like for me to grow as
a human in honor of wanting to become a
person that was worthy
of being my children's mother
and i had a lot to learn i wasn't
raised with
the you know people talk about
boundaries and like i don't know what
they were i wasn't raised with them
i didn't even know what a boundary was
so to talk about that
and to find the liberation to ask for
help what are boundaries how do we learn
them how do we apply them to ourselves
and then our children
and to speak honestly about that it is
hard to figure out how to be a good
human it is hard to raise ourselves let
alone children and your platform allowed
me to come out and get out of my comfort
zone
so thank you for having this profound
conversation with me
and i must say eliza you have changed my
life so thank you elisa dr elizabeth
you can listen to the new episode of
raising good humans tomorrow on apple or
spotify or wherever you cast your pods
[Music]